en este vídeo vamos a ver tres conceptos
muy importantes de estadística para eso
vamos a utilizar esta serie de números
que tenemos acá un 23 29 20 32 otro 23
un 21 un 33 y un 25 entonces
en primer lugar lo primero que vamos a
averiguar es la media
aritmética
media aritmética de esta serie de
números la media aritmética muchas veces
también se la llama promedio
y sin ir más lejos la forma de calcular
la media aritmética es promediando todos
los números que tenemos por lo tanto
para calcular entonces la media
aritmética de esta serie de números
tendríamos que hacer
23 más 29 más 20 más 32 más 23 otra vez
más 21 33 más 25 y a todo esto dividirlo
por la cantidad de elementos que sumamos
es decir realizamos la sumatoria de
todos los elementos que tenemos y a su
vez dividimos esa sumatoria por la
cantidad de números que tenemos en este
caso tenemos 8 números por lo tanto lo
dividimos por 8 entonces tenemos que la
sumatoria de todos estos números
y si hacemos 206 / 8 obtenemos como
resultado 25 a 75 y este es el valor el
número de nuestra media aritmética es el
promedio entonces de todos los valores
que tenemos de la suma todo de la lista
de números que tenemos 25 75 y fíjense
que es un número que no está en nuestra
nuestra lista de números sin embargo eso
me interesa podemos utilizarla igual en
segundo lugar vamos a utilizar vamos a
conocer el concepto de mediana el
concepto de mediana es más bien de
ubicación ya que una vez que acomodamos
todos estos números que tenemos de menor
a mayor de la siguiente forma tenemos el
20 21 23
el otro 23 el 25 el 29
el 32 y el 33 lo que hacemos es buscar
el centro de la lista en este caso el
centro está acá y no hay ningún número
por lo tanto buscamos los dos valores
que tenemos en el centro es decir
tenemos una mediana con dos valores y
para encontrar el valor exacto de esto
lo que tenemos que hacer es la media
aritmética o el promedio de esos dos
valores es decir 23 más 25
dividido a la cantidad de números que
sumamos que es 2 y esto es igual al 24
por lo tanto la mediana también es un
valor que no está dentro de nuestra
lista y que es 24 vamos a escribirlo
esto es igual a 24 y por último el
último
insisto valga la redundancia de los
conceptos que vamos a trabajar en este
vídeo es el de la moda
la moda también es un concepto muy muy
muy sencillo
fíjense que cuando nosotros hablamos de
moda en cuestiones de vestimenta nos
referimos a la vestimenta que más se usa
que más se ve bien es en el caso de
estadística también la moda va a ser el
número que más veces aparezca fíjense
que en este caso el número que más veces
aparece es el 23 que aparece dos veces
el resto de los números aparece una vez
cada uno a usar este color para
discriminar los mejor
tenemos entonces el 23 la moda es 23
entonces en este vídeo lo interesante
que pudimos comprender son los conceptos
de mediana
mediana media aritmética y moda